hey guys Pete here as I mentioned
yesterday in my twin peak season 810
things you might have missed video this
is going to be my 10 things from the
secret history of Twin Peaks that could
be really important for season 3 video
so this is something that I wanted to do
for a while that is a little bit
daunting and that's because there's so
much stuff in the secret history of Twin
Peaks there is a spoiler warning
necessary here this will give up a
couple of things that you don't know
when you start reading the book that are
specific to it however at the same time
this is only going to point out some
interesting things from the book it's
not a replacement for reading it I
suggest that everyone reads it
themselves the hardcover is a great
addition to any collection of Twin Peaks
stuff I mean it's really cool and the
audio book is actually a little bit more
coherent because then there you know
it's narrated by actor so everything
goes in a straight line there is a link
in all of my Twin Peaks videos to check
out the book in more detail on Amazon so
check that out if you haven't seen it
yet because I'm not going to get into
every little detail about the book
itself so the history of Twin Peaks was
written by co-creator of the series Twin
Peaks mark frost it was released on
October 18th 2016 it's put together as a
dossier of documents that someone named
the archivist puts together about this
the town of Twin Peaks and it is
annotated by FBI special agent TP who's
been assigned to figure out what's going
on with it by Gordon Cole so the first
thing in the book that stands out right
away is the inclusion of the history of
the Al Cave ring this is the gold ring
that we've seen in the series ever since
fire walk with me and we learn right in
the beginning of the secret history that
this thing has been around for a while
now we know the Teresa Banks Aunt Laura
Palmer were both wearing the ring when
they died but the featured history
actually tracks it all the way back to
Meriwether Lewis of
Lewis and Clark and they were given the
ring by the nez perce a tribe of Native
Americans and specifically by one of
their Chiefs twisted hair listed himself
did not wear the ring he actually
carried around a little leather pouch
but in the twin peaks' universe there
are quite a few people that we know who
have worn it related to the TV show and
the movie and this book so secret
history tells us that chief twisted hair
got a ring from what he described as
white giants they gave him three
artifacts including the ring it's worth
noting here that there shouldn't have
been any white people in this region
before Lewis and Clark so there's it's
easy to speculate here that the white
Indians that are supposedly Giants this
could definitely be tied to the giant
that we know from the TV series and
beyond
so Meriwether Lewis was known to wear
the ring when he died it was stolen from
his corpse by a guy named James Neely
Aleister Crowley may have wore the white
ring we don't know for sure but we do
know that Jack Parsons who we'll talk
about later wore the ring on his right
ring finger next time we hear about it
Richard Nixon the President of the
United States at one time is wearing the
ring on his right finger then Empire
walk with me we know that we saw it on
Teresa banks hand in that picture and
this is the first time we hear about an
arm going numb as you could see in that
picture she word on her left ring finger
not on the right after her death we saw
Chester Desmond pick up the ring under
the trailer in the fat trout and then he
disappeared and never be seen again
later in fire walk with me we see Philip
Michael Girard or Mike wearing the ring
and he obviously only has one arm so
he's wearing it on the pinky finger when
we see it there
the man from another place shows the
Dean of the ring to Cooper in the Red
Room and then Laura Palmer ends up
wearing it which seems to ward off Bob
from being able to possess her she got
it from Mike who threw it at her
and that force Bob to kill her Amy wore
the ring on her left ring finger we saw
it when she came out of the log a nurse
at the hospital took the ring from an
unconscious Annie and she wore it on her
left ring finger and the last time we
saw it was when dougie Jones was wearing
it on his left ring finger and of course
he told Jade his arm was numb and then
when he was transported to the Red Room
we saw his arm kind of shrivel up and it
fall off and Mike would appear to be in
possession of the ring now so there's a
lot of other stuff that goes along with
this ring and but we can't talk about it
all day but I think it's safe to say
that it's important as we've already
seen it in season 3 and the importance
is just furthered by the idea that the
book explains where it came from right
in the very beginning so the next big
thing we learn is that dougie milford
who was only in season 2 is actually a
pretty mysterious and important
character most of the secret history is
about this guy and I think everyone was
surprised to find out that he was
involved in all that he was involved
with so basically he was a twin peaks'
local he grew up there he had an
experience as a child where he claims to
have seen a giant and a man-sized
walking al near Glastonbury Grove and he
got a three triangle mark similar to
what we saw on Briggs later as a result
after that he cannon became the town
drunk for a while and then he got into a
fight with his brother Dwayne which we
saw carry on in season two and he sort
of disappeared after Pearl Harbor he
enlisted in the United States Army Air
Corps he got in some trouble there and
once he did he got reassigned to the
White Sands Missile Range while there he
saw the detonation of the nuclear bomb
that we saw a couple times in season 3 a
couple years later he was transferred to
Roswell New Mexico it's the place you
probably heard and he actually saw some
debris from that
from this UFO crash at that time after
that he ended up being an investor
becoming an investigator where he
investigated alleged UFO sightings and
other phenomenon and this brought him in
contact with a couple of other
characters Margaret Coulson the log lady
collar rod and another guy Allen true
aim who were abducted as children in the
Twin Peaks area he ended up in Project
Blue Book and during that time he
investigated a guy that we will talk
about later Jack Parsons so he ended up
working for Nixon Blue Book gets shut
down but he ends up getting to keep on
working on these cases through Nixon
once Nixon gets in trouble and has to
resign his presidency he continues his
work but we find out that the only
person that he could trust in the
government was Gordon Cole in his 60s he
returns to Twin Peaks he took over the
paper and he set up a base that we'll
talk about later called and listening
post alpha it's interesting here to know
that Phil Jeffries and Gordon Cole were
sent to look at what was going on after
there was some writing about it and they
reported that it was part of Ronald
Reagan Star Wars project later he
hand-picked major garland Briggs who we
know from the series to be his successor
at The Listening Post and then we know
that he ended up marrying Lana in season
two and then passed away after their
wedding so dougie is a very important
character and he was basically involved
with all sorts of things that are
related to you know unexplained
activities and so even though he's no
longer in the story his work still
continues today the third thing that is
important from this book is what I was
just talking about next listening post
alpha now remember this was set up sort
of outside of the regular channels of
the government Gordon Cole knew about it
so Jeffries knew about it but most other
people had no idea what was going on
Milford build it to his own
specifications and then he brought in
Briggs to run it and
what you know we kind of got that from
Briggs all the time that he could not
tell us why he was there what he did
because it was top secret so what's
interesting about listening post alpha
is that there's a very good chance that
this could be where the idea of blue
rose cases come from we don't know for
sure and we probably never will but
there's a lot of interesting things than
the other things that we're going to
talk about in this video that make it
seem like it's very possible either way
we know that at the time of Laura
Palmer's death that listening post alpha
was going along with major Briggs
overseeing everything and we know that
dougie milford left him with
instructions to wait for his next
controller so we'll get into that in a
bit the next thing that could certainly
be important about the secret history
was the introduction of the TP character
who verified the documents inside the
dossier at Gordon's instruction by the
end of the book we realized that T P
stands for Tamara Preston and that is
Tammy from season three now you have to
remember that the events in season three
occur 25 years after 1989 which puts it
in 2014 the actual events of her looking
over the book in the secret history
happens in 2016 so even though she was
introduced this way the book actually
you know everything that she does in the
book happens after season threes
completed so what's important about
Tammy here is that we learned a lot
about her personality she's very similar
to Cooper and to chat Desmond in that
she's very professional she seems really
highly skilled and competent but at the
same time she's noticeably more
skeptical than at least Cooper is like
she's not quick to jump in and buy a lot
of the stuff that she's reading about
even though she can verify that sources
are legit the next thing that we learned
that could definitely be important is
this guy that I mentioned earlier Jack
Parsons Jack Parsons was a historical
character his story is pulled directly
from real-life events he was the
influential scientist who did a lot of
important work with rocket fuel both
liquid and solid and is basically
responsible for developing this kind of
technology at the same time he was into
occultism and magic especially he was
involved in to lemma which was aleister
crowley's new religious movement and on
several occasions he tried to do some of
these rituals that Crawley laid out this
ended up in him losing his job with JPL
and in 1945 he did a ritual called
babylon working which is actually a
series of rituals but he was doing this
with l ron Hubbard trying to invoke the
Telemachus Babylon to earth so not only
was this guy important in science but
he's also considered a pioneer in the
occult the most important thing I think
that we learned from the secret history
though and what they pointed out is that
he did do the trying to cut he did try
to call forth the goddess Babylon later
he went close to where the Trinity test
happened and tried to do a second ritual
that was forced the elemental entity
known as the moon child to appear this
was also the weekend before the Roswell
incident and this could actually be
related to something that dougie Milford
would see later with President Nixon so
Jack Parsons was a you know he was a
real guy did some crazy stuff and he is
an important character in the secret
history the next one is a character that
was important already but he actually
gets more importance thanks to the
secret history talking about major
Briggs here and we saw major Briggs
disappear and he tells us that he had
gone to the White Lodge he also said
that he had gotten this new three
triangle pattern which was similar to
the one I mentioned with dougie Milford
this is where the connection with
Project Blue Book comes in because he
told Cooper and sheriff Truman that
that's what he did right so he as
mentioned he was in charge of listening
post alpha and after dougie Milford
he got one final message that told him
to continue and that basically no one
was in charge besides him but he had to
wait for his next controller so the
assumption here is is that Gordon Cole
will send him somebody else to work with
so we know some other stuff related to
major Briggs in the Windom Earles
storyline but I'm gonna I'm gonna just
leave that for now what's important for
season 3 is that he eventually realizes
that he believes that Dale Cooper is the
person who's been sent as the new
controller so he thinks that Cooper will
be the person to complete his and Doug
Milford's work so he sets a meeting and
then in the book he finishes by sending
a mayday signal and then we know from
season 3 that he supposedly died the
next day in Cooper left town so as
mentioned Briggs was always important
but we found out that he was really
involved in a lot of stuff that could
give us some an understanding of what
actually happened in and around Twin
Peaks the next things that should
definitely be important for season 3
based on what we know right now is
Gordon Cole and Phillip Jeffries now we
learned in the secret history that they
went through FBI training together at
Quantico and they both were the top two
graduates in the graduating class of
1968 Jeffries while working under Cole
once his visit - Aires and then we saw
him come back and fire walk with me and
we saw that he had been involved with
the lodges on some level and now we know
in season 3 he's been contacting or at
least someone who claims to be him has
been contacting different characters now
when Tammy wrote her notes she mentions
that Phillip Jeffries has never been
seen it's never been verified that he's
been seen since he was in the FBI field
office in Philadelphia back in 1989 we
know from dougie Milford that these two
guys both visited the Twin Peaks area to
set up the cover story for listening
post alpha and we know that Cole
directly was the only person that dougie
Milford trusted in
after Nixon resigned and that coal was
helping a continued project Bluebook so
again we know that Gordon coal is
important we know that he has a
fascination with these blue rose cases
we're learning more and more each day
that Phillip Jeffries is important so
this is something that they really kind
of fill in the history of these two guys
in the book the next thing that's
probably really important for season
three in the secret history is the log
lady and Carl being abducted together
now we know that Margaret as a child was
seen by a physician because that you
know she was thirsty and hungry after
disappearing alongside her classmates
Carl rod and Alan shahane she came back
with a marking that is supposedly the
two mountains in the Twin Peaks area so
it's not the same as the three triangles
we see with the other people but it's a
similar kind of thing
she married Sampson Lanterman who met a
and unfortunate demise he was actually a
champion lumberjack and but he also
worked for the volunteer fire department
and after he died she walked up into the
woods near Glastonbury and cut a log
from one of the Douglas firs that had
dropped during the fire there she got
her log and that's what she's been
carrying around of course that is
definitely the speculation that her
husband is inside of the log you know in
one way or the other but we have no
confirmation of that so we have seen her
in season three and she has been
assisting [ __ ] and colorada we got a ton
of stuff about him because we'd only
seen him in one little bit in fire walk
with me before we get his whole
backstory which of course the abduction
is the most notable thing there so he
basically traveled around for quite some
time and then after a couple of
different tragedies he ended up back in
the Twin Peaks area we're not exactly
sure about the deer meadow thing in fire
walk with me as it seems like it's
slightly in a different place now but
you know that was never cleared up it
was actually made a little bit more
confusing by both the book and season
three but I think it's fair to say
that we know after seeing that yellow
aura that he's able to see after the car
accident we know that Margaret and him
came back with different abilities
related to what happened to them in the
woods that day another thing that came
out of this was and it's no surprise by
any means anymore but we found out that
Audrey survived the explosion at the
bank we found out that Pete Martel
actually was heroic and shielding her
from the blast but we also know that she
slipped into a coma and that's important
for season 3 we don't know how long it
lasted we don't know what's going on
with it but we do know that she had sent
a letter to her father and then he came
back and basically sat by her sat side
almost constantly from what we know we
also know from season three that Cooper
was seen possibly leaving her unit or
near that you know the intensive care
unit but we really don't know what part
Audrey will play and the last thing we
learned that's probably important but I
have no idea why is that there are a ton
of discrepancies in the secret history
there's multiple different threads and
posts and different things that you can
check out out there I made a video about
anywhere I bring out the discrepancies
in her story an enormous story but one
of those things is related to Audrey as
well she writes a letter in you know to
the way the books laid out it's it's not
printed so you know it's photographs of
things and whatever and she writes a
letter to her father about him being
dishonest about its intentions at
ghostwood and it just doesn't line up
with what we know from watching the show
other things are related to that or
Catherine Martell like she just sold the
plant to Ben there was some serious
rewriting with Big Ed and Nadine story
so yeah there's a I'll put a link to the
biggest debt like you know sheet of
different things I think there's 32
major discrepancies between what the
show Canon would be and how the secret
history wrote it up and it really leaves
a makes a big mystery because some of
the things like Annie and other things
that we just know we're totally
different in the show it seems
impossible that it could be done this
way you know that they don't you know
that they're all just air
or whatever like major Briggs we find
out major Briggs is the archivist by the
end and he was compiling everything
after Milford passed it off to him and
he describes Pete Martel in one of the
passages as a simple person and the
analogy he uses is something to the
effect that Pete was a you know he that
Pete played checkers not chess and we
know that like Pete was like I would
test master from the window Merle story
so nobody knows for sure why these
things are different but it seems pretty
important that they are of course they
could just be adding to the mystery it
could be to make us wonder if somebody
had altered these documents overtime to
you know change the reality of things
it's just really not sure I mean it
could be that there's more than one
reality or one universe here I don't
know what the implication is but I think
it's a great book I think that we
learned a lot it's definitely like I
said in the beginning it's very well put
together it's very interesting and it's
very Twin Peaks in that it doesn't solve
any mysteries at all I mean it gives us
some some facts that could be true or
might not be true that could be altered
that could be from a different plane of
existence I mean there's all kinds of
supernatural stuff here there's all
kinds of stuff related to UFOs and the
government's work related to this
phenomenon so I don't know it's just a
great it's a great thing to get the
wheels turning in your head I think I
covered the major things here that are
important to season three but there are
a ton of things in this book so I'm sure
that I actually made a conscious effort
to leave all the small details out
because this video is long enough as it
is and it would have been forever
if I were touched on every single thing
so yeah check out the book I hope you
will like this video if you enjoyed it
tell me how you think this stuff ties
into season three if you read the book
if you haven't read the book let me know
what you think in the comments please
subscribe to my channel let me know what
you want to see in future videos and
check back often because I've been on a
roll putting out videos pretty regularly
thanks for watching I'll talk to you
soon